previously i made a video about team
seas the initiative from mr beast and
mark robert to raise 30 million to
remove 30 million pounds of plastic
pollution from the ocean the point of
that video was a general overview of the
project while offering a few criticisms
something that i didn't talk about for
the sake of brevity however was one of
the key aspects of the initiative which
is that the money he raised was being
split between two different
not-for-profits the ocean conservancy a
very well-respected not-for-profit that
focuses on conservation and the ocean
cleanup a different charity that uses
interceptors
the interceptors are a series of
semi-autonomous vehicles that float on
the surface of rivers funneling and
collecting plastic waste for subsequent
disposal the ocean cleanup originally
used similar technology to collect
plastic waste in the open ocean now the
big criticism that myself and experts in
plastic pollution shared about team seas
was its emphasis on cleanup and not
preventing more plastic being added to
the oceans
which is what the interceptors seem to
do mark rober actually made a video
showcasing how the interceptors aim to
turn off the tap of plastic that
currently pours into the ocean but while
on first glance the interceptors seem to
turn off the tap of plastic pollution
the real picture is a bit more complex
and the fact that it is complex is one
of the issues here
[Music]
the interceptors work by collecting
plastic that floats on top of rivers
very sensible but yeah my name is dr tim
van emerick i'm an assistant professor
in hydrologic sensing at the vagranga
university in the netherlands and i lead
the plastic team that focuses on river
plastic pollution and it's basically a
project that focuses on developing the
right tools to be able to quantify river
plastic pollution in any river around
the world well i mean if you just look
around you how many different kinds of
plastics you find in your daily life
well multiply that with two three five
or ten and that's what they find in
rivers basically everything that you can
imagine that's made out of plastic i
think we found it in a river somewhere
what we find here in the makong is an
incredible amount of foams that's very
different from rivers in for example
ghana or the netherlands in ghana a lot
of drinking water is sold in plastic
sachets rather than bottles than the
european rivers or we find completely
different items again so there we find
mainly food packaging cigarette butts
bottles and bottle caps in our in our
work we
differentiate between different river
compartments especially say you have the
the plastic floating at the surface you
have the submerged plastics in the water
column but you can also find them on the
river bed you can find them in the
sediments you find them under river
banks on the floodplains
in the vegetation but also in biota or
entrapped in vegetation so you find it
everywhere so you might say well fine
but if the largest proportion of plastic
pollution on a river is that which isn't
floating at the surface then it makes
sense to concentrate your efforts there
right unfortunately however each river
around the world has its own unique
ecosystem of plastic pollution no two
rivers are alike last december we've
been
collecting data in the oda river in
ghana the amount of pollution is more or
less the same but the river itself is
completely different where the odor
river is a river that is at most maybe
60 centimeters wide comparing that with
the mekong river which ends up in at
least i think nine branches each branch
can be up to a kilometer wide when it
enters the sea both in terms of
collecting data and collecting plastics
before it enters the ocean it requires a
completely different approach in my
opinion so the interceptor's
effectiveness will vary wildly depending
on the river they're deployed on but
will still result in a reduction in
ocean plastics well i have to say i
cannot really confirm that because there
are situations so one of the rivers
we've studied we estimated that more
than half the plastics can actually be
submerged in the water column so if
you're only focusing on the top on the
floating part both as scientists but
also as i guess stakeholders or those
planning interventions um yeah you miss
out a great deal specifically when we
look at the larger items
we actually think that most of the
plastic pollution that leaks into the
into nature does not end up in the ocean
so a recent recent study that was
published in science advances uh
estimated that less than two percent of
the total amount of plastic that is
leaking to the environment makes it into
the ocean meaning that 98 of the plastic
pollution
stays somewhere else could be either on
land around the liver systems or within
the river system themselves interceptors
simply aren't going to stop plastic
pollution in the ocean even if they were
floated on every single river on the
planet and furthermore aren't even going
to stop plastic pollution in rivers due
to just focusing on one part of a
complex system and as we'll see later
this isn't because the problem is
unsolvable and the interceptor is the
best but imperfect solution we have in
fact they're an extraordinarily bad way
to stop ocean plastic pollution so why
are they being proposed as a solution
even a temporary solution which is to be
fair what the ocean cleanup says they
are in the first place well partly
because they collect the plastic at the
surface which is the easiest to see how
to collect but more fundamentally
because of how we think about technology
and solving problems
[Music]
the interceptors are a top-down
one-size-fits-all solution using
exciting new technology a conveyor belt
of trash solar panels water collection
it's like something tony stark would
design for a not insignificant number of
people especially those who are vocal
online this use of new technology is the
most appealing aspect of projects like
this one but also others like the spacex
starship project they represent the
forward-thinking technological modern
society driven by science and how we
should be doing things across all
sectors this is a whole philosophical
thing that i am not qualified to talk
about abby thorne can make a video about
this and its problems if she wants
though i am not going to stand here and
complain about people following science
and wanting to see more of it
but we do need to talk about the
difference between science and
technology science is the process of
identifying something that we do not
understand collecting data about it and
then using that data to answer our
questions it's vulnerable to the biases
of the people doing the science but when
analysis of carefully collected data is
objective it's the least worst system
we've come up with technology on the
other hand is the use of knowledge
acquired through science to do well
whatever you like really modern
technology is just technology
constructed through modern science when
people look up to the activities of the
ocean cleanup or spacex or tony stark
they're not idolizing science they're
idolizing the outcome of recent science
the use of new technology crucially
however that new technology while the
product of science can be applied in
such a way that is informed by
scientific methodology
or not for example based on a recent
paper i could invent a device that tells
you how many amphibians there are in a
10 meter radius great new technology
based on other scientific papers that i
could then put this invention into
action to help monitor the spread of
chi-tridiomycosis a disease that's
devastating amphibian populations in
central america
or i could send it to the moon because
that would be cool the cool new
technology was informed by science but
my use of it was not informed by science
in fact it consciously rejected data
that we had available we know that there
are no amphibians on the moon so with
all that being said and the technology
of the interceptors being undeniably
cool
are they the solution to this problem in
fact is new technology really the
solution to this problem i think that
solving ecological problems is often
less about the exact tech you have and
more about the people and the
initiatives and the attention that you
have going into it so in that case there
are definitely problems that can be
solved by tech but so many of our
problems are problems of attention and
priorities that's dr virginia schutte an
ecologist and science communicator whose
phd was in coastal ocean conservation in
other words about the perfect person to
talk to about tmc's in general i have a
positive reception to cleaning up
plastic before it gets scattered in the
great wide you know deep sea kind of
area the funny thing about the
interceptor though is even though it's
marketed as brand new technology shiny
just developed it is as far as i and
others can tell nearly an exact copy of
technology that has been in operation
for decades already the closest match to
the interceptor is called mr trash wheel
it's in maryland and it's been operating
scooping trash for years out of a harbor
not the middle of the river where
wildlife needs to travel but a harbor
where river currents naturally gather
things like they do in in the great
pacific garbage patch the current sweep
things into the harbor area this tech
has been used before in a different
context and is not appropriate for this
use case especially because the
environments that it needs to operate in
vary so wildly
something that the science very clearly
says
but the ocean cleanup are willfully
ignoring like looking for sick
amphibians on the moon the interceptor
is cool technology used in a way not
guided by the scientific literature both
in the boats themselves but also in the
ocean cleanups plan to use the same
solution on dozens eventually hundreds
of rivers you need to customize you can
have the same idea that you take to
different communities but you have to
customize it to fit the people that live
there there's that justice component to
make sure that their needs are being met
while also working with local customs
local culture manufacturing a single
solution and saying i will drop it into
areas across the world it's just not an
approach to conservation that i agree
with and furthermore the ocean cleanup
is so secretive that it's difficult to
work out how effective they're really
being without wishing to drag the
organization unnecessarily a few
questions have emerged about the way
they do things for example pre-sorting
plastic waste for photo opportunities
over-egging how effective their devices
are a lack of transparency in how
effective the devices are the evidence
seems to indicate they're really not
effective ignoring data and the advice
of experts on how to best solve the
problem and acting as a green washing
front for large corporations a cynic not
me of course would say that the ocean
cleanup was never about trying to clean
up plastic pollution instead being more
concerned with a self-sustaining cycle
of publicity and funding pursuing this
technology because it's cool and
generates headlines not because it
actually solves the problem this is my
main problem with team seas they don't
have a bad idea getting plastics out of
the ocean is a great idea they don't
have bad
methods for executing this idea getting
people globally to be excited about this
issue drawing awareness that's great
my issue is when it comes to the ocean
cleanup no problems with the ocean
conservancy they're wonderful but when
it comes to the ocean cleanup
there are better proven systems that
already exist so there is no need to
settle
for a solution that is not the best
there is a report written by a global
organization saying that we already have
all the tech we need to accomplish
reducing plastic by it's something
ridiculous like 80
and we can accomplish this in the next i
think it's 20 to 30 years
so if collection of floating plastic
isn't going to fix this problem
what will
well fortunately we have a methodology
that allows us to identify problems and
then answer questions about them in the
least worst way we can
science
it's defining and quantifying your
problem if you don't know what the
problem is it will be extremely
difficult to tackle it and demonstrate
that you have solved the problem that if
you would just compare the concentration
of floating plastics in the great
pacific garbage patch to i would say any
riverbank in europe you already see that
the concentration of plastics on the
riverbanks are about 200 times higher
than in the middle of the great pacific
garbage patch now of course if you then
go closer to the source if you go from
the riverbanks to let's say the the
places where plastics are supposedly
entering river systems sewage outlets or
urban water systems the concentration
can get even much higher so stopping
this thing at the source does not mean
the source of going to the ocean it
means the source of plastic waste
getting into the environment in the
first place instead of looking at
intercepting plastic on rivers then
evidence-based practice indicates that
we should be stopping the plastic from
entering rivers in the first place the
gate in mark's video should be all the
way over here but i want to be clear
that we don't have all the data on the
problem one of the big issues in this
field is actually a lack of data about
what the optimal solution in a given
location will look like it's why
researchers like tim are so important to
help us better understand what we're up
against but what we do understand based
on the data available is that solutions
need to be tailored to a specific
geography to a specific river that's
generally speaking the closer to the
source of plastic action can be taken
the more effective that action will be
and that many strategies are already
known and understood and
we know they will work there's already
so much work that people have done
saying this is exactly what we need if
we have money and attention going to the
right places in the life of waste on our
planet stopping plastics as they go into
the ocean
is kind of like a last resort the amount
of plastics entering the seas is so
large that scooping up a tiny amount of
it will not make very much of a
difference at all those solutions that
already exist include organizations
similar to the ocean cleanup but more
based on evidence-based best practices
such as the river cleanup and water
witch mostly however the solutions are
systematic preventing companies from
producing single-use plastics
substituting plastics with alternatives
and improving the availability of
recycling and waste collection more
broadly crucially what this means on the
ground will vary depending on where you
are higher income countries should focus
on reducing plastic usage and improving
the availability of recycling while
lower-income countries should focus on
improving waste collection and reducing
leakage from waste sites into the
natural environment and those actions
must be taken in collaboration with and
in such a way that empowers local
communities rather than just having a
bunch of rich white guys turning up and
telling you what to do i made some new
friends who after i introduced myself
kept pronouncing my name as gringo for
some reason
the way to generally fix this problem is
with systematic change engaging with the
factors that cause plastic to enter
river systems in the first place so that
means the corporations that produce the
plastic the communities that use the
plastic and the waste disposal or lack
thereof available to those communities
once it's in the river it's kind of too
late to stop the plastic with any degree
of efficiency the literature is very
clear the closer you can take action to
the source of plastic
the better that means at the point of
manufacture
use or disposal
not
whilst it's already floating down a
river
so it's pretty clear that the ocean
cleanup isn't acting based on the
literature either in its method or in
its top-down approach of applying the
same solution everywhere and i'm aware
that the ocean cleanup says this is a
temporary solution and that they want
the systematic change that i've talked
about as i stressed in my previous video
on team seas and the previous previous
video on team trees this is more of an
issue than just picking the wrong
sub-optimal solution when the campaign
receives so much publicity forcing an
illiterate inappropriate solution to a
problem just because it makes for a more
effective public relations campaign
means that you will under deliver on
what you promised and have basically no
impact on the environmental problem at
hand take up all the oxygen in the room
for other environmental campaigns which
would have been more effective and
implant your ineffective methodology in
the public consciousness damaging future
campaigns which would
again be more effective i don't want to
come across as too negative in this
video but i don't think it's
unreasonable to hold the most high
profile environmental campaign in the
history of youtube to a high standard
we deserved better if the tmc's campaign
had taken 15 million and invested it in
improvements in local waste management
we'd be much further on the way in
fixing this problem and be better
equipped to progress further in the
future
as it stands
we're simply not going to see any
significant environmental impact from
this campaign as i also said in my
previous video though if you donated to
team c's then you did a good thing you
took some of your hard-earned money and
gave it away to try and make the world a
better place and i am not and this video
isn't criticizing you or your choice
these are two very famous people at the
head of team seas and they are sparking
people to really care and the ocean
conservancy is a wonderful partner and
so i think the potential for people to
direct millions of dollars and use huge
fame to do good things for the world
that is a trend that i hope continues
forever
i think the change that i'd love to see
is just
making it not a marketing campaign but
giving it a little bit of oversight by
working with scientific organizations
to have them at the advisor level for
the campaign there's no reason if you
have all this money in power that you
can't ask people for input that are have
expertise in this what this video is
saying is that the tmc's partnership
with the ocean cleanup was fundamentally
flawed and a cynic would argue was never
really about trying to fix plastic
pollution at all instead just being a
marketing campaign as a result the
problem is still out there but so is the
solution
it was there all along so let's listen
to the scientists embrace the complexity
and put our money and effort and
attention into a solution that will
actually make a difference
it may not be as sexy or involve new
technology or be as easy to market
but at the end of the day
follows the science what we are trying
to accomplish here is nothing less than
trying to keep our planet habitable for
us and for the myriad species we depend
upon for survival and when this much is
at stake
can we afford to do anything less than
the least
worst option
this video was only made possible with
the support of my patrons at patreon.com
forward slash simon oxfiz if you would
like me to make more videos like this
one that are a bit less sponsor friendly
then please do consider pledging in
return you get early access to videos
and you get some patreon exclusive
content including a monthly
behind-the-scenes vlog thanks must also
go to doctors van emerick and shooti for
helping with this project they were so
generous with their time please do check
out their work linked in the description
and last but not least thank you so much
for watching this video was so hard to
put together because there are just so
many factors you have to balance when
talking about team c's and not all of
them even made it into the video in the
end so
if you did enjoy the outcome and
probably the outcome of the most
difficult writing process of my life
then please do pop the video a like and
let me know what you thought in the
comments here's some recommended videos
from me to watch next if you haven't
already you can subscribe to the channel
down here and if you haven't already you
can also support me on patreon with one
of these links
that just leaves me to say thank you
once again for watching i'll see you in
the next one